the funeral for Florence South Carolina
police sergeant Terrence caraway is set
for Monday the 30 year veteran was
gunned down and several of his
colleagues were wounded Wednesday in an
ambush designed to prevent police from
questioning a suspected child abuser on
Friday bail was denied for the accused
gunman David beg no has more we formally
charged Frederick Hopkins with the
murder of Florence police officer
Carraway the 74 year old Vietnam veteran
and disbarred attorney has also been
charged with six additional counts of
attempted murder that's in connection
with Wednesday's deadly ambush of law
enforcement officers authorities say
three of the officers had arrived at
Hopkins home with a search warrant they
were there to conduct a scheduled
interview with his adopted son Seth who
is accused of sexually assaulting a
child but the investigators never made
it inside can you elaborate on the
ambush they got out of the car and they
were they were shot without warning and
then the responding officers were also
shot on Friday Seth Hopkins was arrested
and charged with criminal sexual conduct
the four children who were in the house
at the time of the ambush are now in
protective custody the city of Florence
continues to honor the memory of fallen
officer Terrence caraway and now
officials have released the names of the
other six law enforcement officers who
were wounded in the shooting rampage for
CBS this morning saturday i'm david beg
know in florence south carolina